the Joe Rogan experience but look people
do what they got to do to stay alive
yes that's we're just so fortunate we
don't have to do that it isn't go to a
crossroads and have a nice vegan real
fuel you want to you're not really
worried about staying alive anymore
we're worried ok primarily about yeah
about well you know people are worried
about the environment and worried about
the health consequences of certain diets
and the environmental consequences of
certain diets and you know and these
people this is what I've really gotten
into after Chris Kresser was on the
podcast recently debunking the game
changers when he was talking about the
positive net benefits of regenerative
farming I don't think that's clearly
been established worldwide or in in
large-scale like in terms of and maybe
it can be like can we do it right feed
yeah yeah can we feed the entire country
on that you know I don't I'm not yeah
you know I think that's I mean that's
the million-dollar question right now -
right like well how are we gonna feed
however many they're predicting like how
we're gonna be the 10 billion people
we're going to see in X number of years
and I think it's interesting and it's
certainly worth thinking about
but like it's also like well how far do
we keep kicking that ball down the road
before we find ourselves in a situation
where like you know then what's the next
question 15 billion 20 billion and so on
and so forth and eventually like you
know we just over populate the world and
it ends really badly for us Z's is
usually a follow overpopulation I think
the real key for us I think is going to
be and I think this is within our
lifetime is going to be lab-created meat
and I think they're really close to
doing that and I think if you have some
sort of ethical lab-created nutritious
meat where you don't have to worry about
suffering or death if if this has been
established then we open up a whole new
avenue of exploration because now you
can say okay all these people that are
vegan for this moral and ethical sort of
dilemma that they have with animal
agriculture killing animals suffering
let's take all that out now you can eat
lab-created meat that has absolutely no
suffering attached to it
let's find out how healthy things really
are and let's find out how many people
stay vegan and how many people revert to
more omnivorous diet which I mean
there's time this is something that
vegans hate to hear but it is a fact 84%
of people who start a vegan diet quit
now is that because of taste is that
because of and then there's the argument
that well people that do it over a long
period of time you get a higher
retention rate that's fine but 84% still
is the number it doesn't matter if you
get a high retention rate for people
that are doing it more than two years or
more than three years
I'll give you stick with it you can do
it no they're just more committed but
the reality is 84% quit this is what's
been firmly established what what would
the number be if there was a cycle
humane lab created meat that had no
suffering attached to it at all it's
just science-based it's just made with
compounds and you know whatever they use
to create this stuff that would be
interesting it'd be interesting to find
out could we eliminate large-scale
animal agriculture in favor of
lab-created meat and what if any
environmental factors would there be
that would be negative that we're
attached to lab-created me because you
have to think whenever you're making
anything right industrial large scale
you're gonna have waste
what is that waste can that waste be
mitigated can they figure out some sort
of a way to have some sort of net
positive effect where that waste is
utilized in some sort of form where it's
it actually can contribute to the
natural processes of you know soil
regeneration and manure and you know
you're composting and things along those
lines
ya know I think it's I think it's
interesting and we're in a interesting
time for sure it'll be interesting to
see where they get with with that and
[Applause]